the world is a scary place  even here in ambani we needed something  to protect us enter the or ar-15 defense  box they took the old Edina model from  the crisis and gave them a complete  makeover they kept us safe for a while I  was at the airport when Rufus detect  robots didn't stand a chance everyone  else gave up on you  but I saw what you could be so I rebuilt  you updated your programming and give  you a hot new personality module  installed system rebooted Ojai 15 online  no that's no good  every great hero needs a real name what  about odisha  I made you to be strong and brave you  still have a lot to learn and you'll  probably mess up sometimes but I know  you'll become the hero we need my name  is ELISA I will keep you safe that is my  primary function  you